I actually think I would get long here
on this.
Um, as it's come up and it's it's done a
50% pullback. It's gone past that
actually. And if it pulls back and
breaks higher, I think that's a good
it's just a really good sweep lower.
Um, it's kind of nerve-wracking getting
in on this volatility
a little bit, but
I like it to
the long side as,
you know, potential of just a
a sweep lower
and then we push higher.
I think I'm pretty much just going to
have my stop below this. Yeah, this is
hard. Maybe I should have waited for a
little bit more of a pullback, but or or
a close on this. You know, that's kind
of my um nerves talking there.
But, you know, really what I was looking
for was a pullback and then a quick
spike lower and then I think a shoe
higher because again, I think this could
just sweep back pretty quickly. Uh, and
if I waited much longer, you know, maybe
I could have waited to get long on the
the high of this candlestick and see how
this reacts. But again, it's then it's
just, you know, you're just nickel and
dimeing at that point and and going back
and forth. Um,
so my bias is big picture is to the
upside and this is just kind of a sweep
lower.
Uh, I could get sweeped out. I I could
get knocked out just because it it could
pull back and then do one more an actual
like larger, you know, fivem minute
pullback and then go higher.
Well, hopefully this doesn't take as
agonizingly long as my gold trade
yesterday, but
um that's kind of where we're at. I'm
going to move my stop up a tiny bit just
to the lows of this. I think at this
point if it if it pulls back it's, you
know, going to knock me out. I might as
well just put my risk where I actually
would like it. Um, and I think it looks
good. So, I think just kind of waiting
to see. um the the initial I'd probably
move my stop to break even when it
breaks this as a high, but it could
definitely come up here and retest this
in terms of a bigger picture swing
looking because this is really a micro
pullback in terms of you know bottoming
uh this move right here makes total
sense. So even if it comes up to here, I
might not move to break even if I think
the big picture bias is still re really
looking good. Um I think if it does come
up here, I think holding through a
pullback like that is it makes a lot of
sense.
So until then, I think it's
it's got to be just
hold on, wait, and and let it do its
thing. And
um the ES and and NASDAQ are just
grinding higher here. Uh they've just
gone into insane slumber. Uh even on a
fivem minute, it's kind of just looks
like it's doing a pullback and
continuing higher. So uh it's at the
9:00 reversal 90 minutes after the
market opens timing. So you know, we
could get a a final spike here. I think
what I need to see here is a final spike
higher and then a
uh you know a pullback and then a lower
high. You know something showing that
there's movement going. Um and until
then you know just letting it play out.
But if it keeps going higher I don't
know. Gold seems to be following that a
little bit. So,
uh, if I'm in long gold and it goes up,
that's it's totally fine by me with one
trade. Again, I want to see this come up
here and and do I want to hold through a
pullback here. So,
I'm going to just kind of let this do
what it needs to do. And so, while we
wait for this, Ninja Trader is having a
$400,000
demo trading tournament. I kid you not,
there is $400,000 up for grabs. And so I
highly recommend if you're new to Ninja
Trader or you have an account, you can
sign up. It's completely free and you're
demo trading. So you're literally
potentially making real money. I think
the grand prize is up to $100,000 with
literally zero risk. So it's almost
silly to not sign up. You can sign up
through this QR code or the link below.
Okay. Definitely some whipsaws here on
gold. That's kind of spooky, but held
through the pullback I want. And you
know, that's that's what I'm looking
for. So, again, just just got to hold
on. Uh
I'm always out of breath when I come
back because I just I just ran up the
stairs. Um NASDAQ and ES
I think they're just going to chop
around. I'm not really interested. I
think I'm just going to sit in gold
unless they really start making some
kind of move. Uh I'm just going to kind
of let them do their thing.
Dang. So, at a break even or not at
break even, a loss on that.
I really thought that pullback was going
to look good. Um,
looking at
NASDAQ and ES, that's still a nice
This looks better on the NASDAQ,
honestly.
It's a nice high and a lower high.
Uh,
I think it looks better on the NASDAQ. I
would like to see essentially it come
here,
see how this test looks.
and then potentially get in on a lower
high short.
This was
and pretty nice signal here, but
obviously I wasn't here.
I'm nervous, but I do really want to get
short. I want to see how this candle
finishes forming and then I think I'll
get short on a low a break of it.
I really wish my stop was a little
wider.
Potentially just getting short at the
lows here, but also I think it's just
has good potential to just rip lower.
Seven contracts. Holy I almost
accidentally did seven.
That would have been not a good time.
I like this on a fivem minute. I like
just using it one minute as an entry
signal and a five minute looks really
good. The ES hasn't rolled over yet,
which is a little concerning,
but I also think the NASDAQ might be
leading this.
So, I'm just going to go
um
you know, put this down here at 3x and
go walk away for a couple minutes
because there's nothing I can do for
right now.
O ES doesn't look good. So, this is kind
of what I was worried about. ES is just
climbing up and that's dragging the
NASDAQ.
The thing is though here, if the ES does
roll over, NASDAQ's going to roll over
hard,
but it just seems unlikely. Did I just
force it a little bit? Hard to know
because I think this looks really good
on a five minute for the NASDAQ.
But I got to be aware that, you know,
the ES is if the ES is leading, it's not
going to let the NASDAQ pull sell off.